nous éprouvons tous allégé passement
patriotique au coeur quand ariane
s'élance impeccablement ne son pas de
tir pour mettre sur orbite une nouvelle
fois sans encombre tel ou tel satellite
mais très honnêtement
lequel d'entre nous à la moindre idée de
ce que représente concrètement une telle
fiabilité
c'est l'objet de ce séduisant carnet du
monde intitulé compte à rebours à kourou
co édité par albin michel et la cité des
sciences de la villette que de les
exposer clairement aux jeunes lecteurs
en détail ayant des saints isabelle
santos et parce qu'elle bouge au sont
donc partis stylo et boîte d'aquarelle
en main pour la guyane française ce
territoire d'amérique du sud a été
colonisé par la france en 1875 il les
départements d'outre-mer depuis 1946 et
on ya vu le premier tir d'ariane en 1979
mois dernier on fêtait le 50e à succès
renouvelé pour la fusée européenne
kourou ce sont quinze mille habitants au
coeur d'une forêt équatoriale qui
couvrent 94 % du territoire
mais la guyane c'est aussi le camp de la
transportation le bagne de l'île du
diable ça laurent du maroni oublier
auprès de son fleuve et les épaves des
cargos qui rouillent pour l'éternité
mais ce sont aussi les plus modernes
technique d'astronautique dont rend
compte si heureusement ce petit livre
qui devrait intéresser tous les publics